hello everyone welcome to Amex logic
bioinformatics and data science
Community my name is sonalika Ray and
I'm the project manager and training
instructor at Pine biotech till date we
have trained over half a million
students from across the globe in
bioinformatics and data science and
today we are so excited to welcome you
all for a three-day comprehensive Mentor
guided online workshop on infectious
diseases for drug discovery
in this Workshop we'll be diving deep
into the complex fields of drug
Discovery and explore the latest
breakthroughs and cutting-edge research
in the fight against infectious diseases
this Workshop will also provide an
opportunity for students and researchers
to learn about bioinformatics chem
informatics and Big Data approaches to
understand infectious diseases
it's often easy to get lost in the
details of complex topics like
infectious diseases and Drug Discovery
that's why we have assembled a stellar
group of mentors and support teams to
help you complete this training Workshop
which includes Mr Raja permanent who
will introduce the participants to ever
growing field of Next Generation
sequencing
who will cover the basics of chem
informatics and its applications in drug
Discovery and Dr raghavendra in Lakshmi
Narayanan who will provide an overview
of the different types of omics data and
their integration for infectious disease
research
at the end of this Workshop participants
will have a thorough understanding of
genomic surveillance and its role in the
control and elimination of infectious
diseases sequence alignment techniques
for identifying evolutionary
relationships between the sequences
transcriptorm analysis for quantifying
post-molecular response to pathogen
Invasion and cheminformatics
applications for discovering new agents
against various infectious diseases and
lots more
this Workshop will be conducted through
life mental guidance sessions and
Technical Support teams
you will get a comprehensive
asynchronous coursework at cells for a
month and case studies based on Exemplar
projects on the omixologic learn portal
not only this may also go through our
practical hands-on experience with
bioinformatics tools using debioinfo
platform and publicly available data
repositories and tools we'll also go
through the available chem informatics
tools and biological data sets through
Geo ncpi SRA pdb Etc
the first session of this Workshop will
introduce the participants to NGS and
its role in detection and
characterization of infectious disease
pathogens at the end of this session the
participants will have a thorough
understanding of NGS for identification
of new variants and the development of
vaccines surveillance and control of
antimicrobial resistance and pathogens
and also learn about the importance of
genomic surveillance in Infectious
Disease Control
in the second session of the workshop we
will take the participants one step
further and will provide an overview of
the different types of formix data and
their relevance to infectious disease
research this includes integration and
Analysis of various omics data sets such
as genomics transcriptomics and
metuchenomies
at the end of this session the
participants will be equipped with the
skills and the knowledge that are
necessary to analyze and interpret
multi-omics data for infectious disease
research such as sarskov 2 Ebola and
malaria
the final session of this Workshop is
designed to cover the basics of chemical
informatics and its applications in drug
Discovery for infectious disease
research the session will also include a
Hands-On component where attendees will
have the opportunity to perform wage
analysis on Project data sets and at the
end of this session the participants
will have a thorough understanding of
different computational tools and
techniques that could be used in chem
informatics to identify potential drug
targets and Drug candidates
these methods will include Hands-On
exercise on the debioinfo platform which
provides a simple and intuitive
interface for processing analysis and
machine learning methods for
multi-ohomics data
so so whether you are a seasoned
researcher or a curious newcomer this
Workshop is sure to provide valuable
insights and knowledge into this crucial
area of medicine the program
participants will also get a certificate
of completion and Excellence at the end
of this training Workshop that can be
added to your resume and shared on
social network
so sit back relax and get ready to learn
and engage with our expert speakers and
fellow participants as we dwell into the
exciting world of infectious disease and
drug Discovery enroll now and let's get
started